[Música]
é como todos já sabem eu sou graduada em
enfermagem que queria mostrar para vocês
que foi a profissão que eu escolhi pra
mim eu sempre sonhei em ser enfermeira e
quando eu passei no vestibular foi a
maior alegria da minha vida e me formei
na universidade de uberaba e hoje eu vou
mostrar pra vocês um pouquinho do que é
que me estimulou a mudar ea deixar a
enfermagem um pouquinho de lado ou
totalmente de lado não é digamos assim
hoje é e passar a migrar para a
fotografia como a minha profissão e o
grande amor da minha vida digamos assim
questão de trabalho é um dos maiores
fatores que me fez mudar foi a doença e
morte do meu pai porque eu já tinha me
formado quando nós descobrimos o câncer
dele e gente já não tinha mais o que
fazer ou seja somente cuidar para que
ele tivesse um melhor momento na partida
dele né
e foi o que eu fiz me dediquei 24 horas
a deixá lo bem
enfim sendo assim foi muito difícil pra
mim lidar com o processo de dor e de
morte de um ente querido
mediante ao aspecto da saúde e da dessa
profissão que a gente lida praticamente
todo o tempo com isso a gente lida muito
mais com a dor e morte do que a
felicidade do próximo é logo em seguida
ao descobrir a minha primeira gestação
logo em seguida que ele faleceu já tinha
me formado e foi um susto eu não estava
esperando estava estudando pra prestar
concurso aquela coisa toda mas foi uma
alegria também porque um dos meus
maiores sonhos era ser mãe eu não sabia
quando eu era jovem quando eu tinha uns
12 anos o que eu queria ser na vida é
questão de profissão mas
queria ser mãe eu sempre soube enfim é
logo que eu tive minha primeira filha
ela tinha nove meses descobri que eu
estava mais uma vez e foi extinto e não
gente não o programado
muitas pessoas me perguntam se eu
programei mas não programei é e uma
coisa que me prendia demais dentro da
enfermagem uso livre da criatividade
porque eu sempre fui uma pessoa criativa
sempre gostei de coisas diferentes e
dentro da enfermaria ficava muito presa
nem a tudo e e tão bem como eu disse no
início eu fui em busca a vivenciar o
amor né ea felicidade das pessoas porque
dentro da enfermagem não conseguia é
vivenciar isso era muito muito difícil a
gente conseguir vivenciar isso né
e daí o que é que eu precisei é o que
foi necessário né para que eu pudesse é
transformar a minha vida profissional eu
precisei de algumas táticas digamos
assim né é primeiro estudar muito porque
era uma profissão nova que eu não
conseguia não sabia nada eu sempre soube
que eu gostava muito de fotografia
sempre mas eu não sabia a técnicas é o
domínio do equipamento eu preciso
estudar o domínio dos softwares né de
edição porque não é só na fotografia mas
a edição você também coloca sua
personalidade
daí a sua emoção dentro dela e o seu
estilo né e eu precisava que entrar no
mercado do trabalho com um diferencial
fotógrafos na cidade tem muito gente
muito né
parece assim cada dia surge mais enfim
na minha época quatro anos e meio atrás
também tinha muito mas o que é que eu
via
de diferente que eu queria eu não achava
eram fotógrafos de de família que
fizesse uma fotografia mais natural mais
realística né era muito foto em estúdio
aquela coisa tipo fundo branco fundo
pregos apático roupinha era isso né
enfim trouxe pra vocês o meu primeiro
trabalho que foi essas são as minhas
filhas né a diferença de um ano e meio
entre uma e outra foi quando eu estava
estudando e falei eu preciso ver se
realmente eu tô aprendendo
levei ela para um parque e fiz um
piquenique e falei vou fotografar e com
isso eu postei as fotos delas num
véspera de dia das mães e aquilo ali
começou meu box enquanto é um ensaio
fotos do ensaio e eu como assim
calma pedra eu ainda nem se não eu não
estudei precificação eu não estava
preparado ainda no anseio num me lancei
como fotógrafa né eu era simplesmente
uma mãe que tinha uma câmera e tal
estudando que gostava da fotografia
enfim eu resolvi investir pesado em
fotografia de gestante muito estudo
não nego estudei muito estudo muito até
hoje muito luz que é o principal da
fotografia porque através da luz a gente
faz o desenho né da fotografia e daí eu
comecei a trazer um certo diferencial
para a cidade principalmente com
fotografia de tecidos uma fotografia mas
é emocional né não somente pousada eu
sempre gostei de inserir a família
dentro da fotografia a fotografia de
parto é é é a fotografia que pra mim mas
me emociona não tem um parto que eu vá
fotografar e eu não me emociono junto
com a família porque eu já estou naquele
momento inserida na família
eu já estou sabendo de todos os
acontecimentos
dentro do que é à espera daquele bebê e
o que é a chegada daquele filho então eu
tô junto à linha da família neste grande
momento e com isso eu tento sempre
preservar a intimidade da mãe mesmo
sendo um parto normal sem que a mãe
tenha vergonha de mostrar essa foto para
qualquer pessoa
outra coisa no parto eu faço de tudo
porque eles nem percebam que eu estou lá
porque não é nada pousado nada combinado
o parto é uma história que eu tô
contando do momento que eu chego no
hospital
como todas as vezes eu chego antes dos
parques
eu pego eles chegando fazendo assinatura
entrada no hospital no elevador em por
quarto depois no próprio centro
cirúrgico tudo isso são detalhes que eu
tento pegar para guardar pra essa
família tese registro de uma história
não somente fotos né por exemplo olhar
do primeiro olhar do pai para o filho à
mãe não viu porque a enfermeira entregou
o bebê para o pai e ea mãe tava lá atrás
ela nem percebeu isso isso pra mim é um
momento muito importante a família vendo
o bebê pela primeira vez a mãe tá lá
dentro fácil hoje tudo está acontecendo
a história não para entender o parto não
existe foto repetida por isso que eu
entrego todas as fotos tamanho do pai
porque eu não acho justo colocar uma mãe
para escolher foto não tem como
é outra coisa fotografia newborn quando
eu comecei a fotografar não tinha isso
na cidade é e aí o que que eu precisei
me especializar
a primeira coisa me ajudou o meu curso
de mais porque antes de eu ser fotógrafo
eu sou enfermeira então toda a
fisiologia do bebê e eu já conhecia eu
já sabia como manipular um bebê
qual a posição que eu poderia colocar o
que eu não poderia fazer porque antes de
uma foto bonita pra mim a segurança vem
em primeiro lugar
então assim é isso que eu tento passar
para os pais confiança o pai mas a mãe
chega no meu estúdio a mãe entrega o
bebê pra mim e ela só recebe o bebê de
novo na hora que precisa amamentar
porque é livre demanda e na hora de ir
embora que eu entrego bebê trocado de
roupa e pronto pra mãe então os pais têm
total segurança eles entregam minha mãe
fala faz o que precisa ser feito e é
isso que eu tento fazer fotos com que a
gente perceba que o bebê nem ele do meu
tempo todo tem bebê que entra no estúdio
do ministério domindo gente vocês estão
sentindo isso imagina eu a cada ensaio
eu quero morrer todos eles e quando
chega àquele dos pezinhos parece pão
eu fico toca né
então assim eu tenho sempre entregá amor
não somente fotos né da mesma forma que
quando eu quis fazer enfermagem foi por
amor quando eu decidi passar para a
fotografia também foi amor e uma das
coisas que eu sempre coloco na frente do
meu trabalho a emoção na frente de
qualquer técnica mediante de qualquer
momento
a história dessa foto a mãe estava
gestante de gêmeos e quando o bebê
nasceu a linha não sobreviveu
e ela me pediu que eu fizesse pra ela
uma foto que representasse o bebê dela
mas que fosse uma foto que ela olhasse
com amor e com alegria e ela não sabia
como eu poderia fazer isso quando ela
chegou no estúdio que ela viu ela chorou
de emoção
a briga ficou dani essa é a foto da
minha vida
pode ter certeza que essa é a foto da
minha vida que a minha pequena sofia
hoje é o anjo do hotel
então outra coisa que eu era relutante
com a questão do acompanhamento porque
porque eu nunca gostei muito daquelas
fotinhas é temáticas digamos assim né
a e b vestido de chaves o bebê vestido
daquilo eu nunca gostei porque eu sempre
imaginei assim meu eu como bebê daqui 15
anos eu me ver vestida de chiquinho vou
falar meu minha mãe achou que eu era o
que uma uma menina de rua com esse
cabelo fica uma aqui outra ti como assim
então eu sempre eu as minhas fotografias
eu tento fazer elas de uma forma
atemporal porque daqui 15 anos e um bebê
essa foto ou seja ela vai ser um rapaz
né elevado mesmo jeito que amanhã hoje
não tem muita diferença né e outra coisa
eu sempre trabalho muito com açores
eu gosto de cores vibrantes e
contrastantes porque é usando isso eu
coloco quem evidência a criança que é o
principal motivo da fotografia
então assim eu precisei também estudar e
buscar o meu estilo para trazer isso
para os meus clientes e principalmente
eu não faço fotos mês
amei porque uma das coisas que a
enfermagem também ajudou o bebê
a mudança neuromotor do bebê ela
acontece trimestralmente não é
mensalmente então todo mês você não
consegue ver realmente o desenvolvimento
do bebê
enfim eu trouxe isso também que não
tinha que o meu ensaio é trimestral e
três seis nove 12 são quatro sessões
a mãe faz comigo primeiro eu sou mãe eu
sei que não é fácil sair de casa todo
mês com um bebê pequeno é tenso
caí no método já é uma semana programado
para ir no médico e levam a marca
apresenta viajando há sim uma semana
imagina se todo mês tem que sair para
fazer foto seu filho
segundo a o bebê não aguenta muito tempo
porque saiu da rotina ele vai chorar ele
vai cansar
então os meus ensaios de acompanhamentos
são rápidos é 30 minutos chegou já está
pronto coloquei o bbb fotografa
o outro cenário coloquei fotografei
pronto são dois cenários para a mãe fica
feliz consegui escolher foto e falar
lindo adorei
ainda assim têm dificuldade de escolher
é que é o principal
enfim com isso eu aprendi que todo dia a
gente se transforma todo dia a gente
consegue ser melhor e todos os dias nós
podemos mostrar pro outro que a
transformação não é difícil não é ruim
basta você querer é outro tipo de ensaio
que eu também não fazia smash de keith
gente isso é uma uma técnica que começou
um tipo de fotografia começou nos
estados unidos o que significa um smash
de keiko smash de fruit é o primeiro
contato da criança no seu primeiro ano
de vida com o bolo com o doce e é
exatamente isso faça branca e surge né
e assim é o queridinho das mães nos meus
ensaios trimestrais de 12 meses a mãe já
chega falando assim o de 12 smash né
eu falo é vai ser não preocupa com isso
enfim tem mãe que não quer o doce porque
ela não quer que a criança tem um
contato com 12
e eu particularmente por ser enfermeira
sou super a favor
enfim a gente oferece um smash defronte
que também fica linda criança adora
porque ela já tem esse contato com o
doce do da fruta a fruta ela já está
acostumado durante seis meses então pra
ela não é um bicho de sete cabeças né
enfim logo depois a teodora que impõe na
banheira e eles fazem aquela bagunça é a
hora que mais dá sorriso e as mães ficam
apaixonadas e assim é um ensaio que a
gente curte a mãe o pai eo fotógrafo seu
site tabelada completamente e suja de
bolo de doce de fruta todo o mercado mas
eu gosto disso
isso me deixa feliz né é mais um exemplo
foi o sni
the cake do estado o palhaço pudim
ele chegou pra mim e disse que a dani
ele chama de tio dani e fabíola dani só
com o meu sonho eu falei qual pudim
ele falou assim fazer aquele insights e
faz aqueles neném fica todo o mercado
eu falei vamos fazer nós fizemos esse
foi um dos meus poucos ensaios temáticos
e que a ele foi o melhor presente que
ele pode receber na vida e eu fico muito
feliz com isso né
então uma coisa que eu sempre põe sempre
sempre falo nunca deixe que sua técnica
sobressaem sua criatividade e emoção
porque quando você põe a emoção na
frente tudo vai ficar muito melhor e
hoje gente eu vim aqui pra mostrar pra
vocês que eu me transformei que eu mudei
é para uma profissão nada a ver do que
eu fazia
mas é algo que me deixa muito feliz
muito feliz mesmo levanto de manhã eu
não tenho a sensação que eu vou
trabalhar eu levanto e falo você feliz
hoje eu vou fazer a foto mais linda da
minha vida porque eu amo o que eu faço
então como eu me transformei eu deixo
essa pergunta hoje pra vocês e vocês
também querem se transformar em kerem
mudar
e aqui eu deixo para vocês pensarem
espero que tenham gostado
[Aplausos]
[Música]